a quien llamaban "la mejor de nosotras."
Ella era una pequeña rubia muy dinámica,
que apenas media metro sesenta.
Y era una mezcla salvaje entre Martha Steward,
y la teniente O'Neil.
A ella le encantaba preparar la comida para su marido,
su amor en el ROTC de Kent State quien la animó a superarse,
y a confiar en sí misma,
y a ponerse a prueba ante cada límite.
También le encantaba cargarse unos 23 kilos a la espalda y correr kilómetros,
y deseaba ser un soldado.
Solía tener una máquina panificadora en su oficina en Kandahar,
y horneaba pan de pasas y después se iba al gimnasio
y se levantaba 25 o 30 veces de una barra de dominadas.
Era una persona que, si necesitabas un par extra de botas
o comida casera, estaba en los números de marcación rápida.
Porque nunca te hablaba
sobre lo buena que era,
sino que lo demostraba con acciones.
Era famosa por no tomar el camino fácil.
Y también por acercarse a una cuerda de 4 kilómetros y medio,
ascender por ella utilizando solo los brazos,
y después alejarse mientras se disculpaba,
porque sabía que se suponía que debía usar los brazos y las piernas,
como los Rangers las entrenaron.
(Risas)
Algunos de los héroes vuelven a casa para explicar sus historias.
Y otros no.
Y un 22 de octubre de 2011.
La teniente Ashley White fue asesinada junto a dos Rangers,
Christopher Horns
y Kristoffer Domeij.
Su muerte lanzó a este programa construido en la sombra
a ser el centro de atención.
Porque después de todo,
la prohibición de las mujeres en combate aún estaba muy arraigada.
Y en el funeral,
el jefe de operaciones especiales vino, y ofreció un testimonio público
no solo por Ashley White,
sino por todo el equipo de hermanas
"No os equivoquéis," dijo, "estas mujeres son guerreras,
y han escrito un nuevo capítulo sobre el significado de ser mujer
en el ejército de los Estados Unidos."
La madre de Ashley es profesora asistente y conductora de autobús,
quien además hornea galletas.
No recuerda mucho acerca de aquellos abrumadores días,
en los que el dolor---gran dolor---
se mezclaba con orgullo.
Pero ella recuerda un momento.
Una desconocida con un niño de la mano se acercó a ella
y dijo, "Sra. White,
he traído a mi hija aquí hoy,
porque quería que supiera qué es un héroe.
Y quería que supiese que los héroes también pueden ser mujeres."
Es tiempo de celebrar todas las heroínas olvidadas
que buscan en su interior
y hallan el corazón y las agallas para continuar y poner a prueba cada límite.
Este grupo inusual de hermanas unidas para siempre en la vida y después
formaron de hecho parte de la historia,
y pavimentaron el camino para las que vendrán después de ellas,
como ellas hicieron con las que hubieron antes.
Ellas mostraron que los guerreros se presentan en cualquier forma y tamaño.
Y las mujeres pueden ser héroes, también.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)